patrick je sais que vous êtes un grand
joueur de ping pong même pas du tout
vous vous avez arrêté pour nos amis mais
vous pouvez reprendre patrick prenez la
raquette patrick alors on les a mené une
grande tâche de pauvres vous voulez
faire une balle d'échauffement bel
échauffement une balle d'échauffement
c'est parti alors ce sera en deux fois
patrick je vous explique en deux points
c'est à dire marando points gagnants
cyril est ce que voulait qu'on fasse
revient l'huissier ou alors là c'était
la balle du jour
non mais on y va alors deux points celui
qui perd qu'est ce qu'il fait il se
détend nu non halal à celui qui perd il
faut que je trouve un truc avant la fin
de mai c'est pas mal il fait du yoga nu
avec gilles verdez mais pas vous celui
qui gagne doit faire du yoga nu avec
gilles verdez alors c'est lui qu'il
gagne il fait du yoga n'y avait qu'un
aura celui qui perd il s'agit
alors allez la saur a laissé partir
alors c'est parti
mais il renvoie le [ __ ] jouer comme ça
pendant deux heures pour tous ces prêts
moi aussi
megan et patrick si vous voulez je fais
un petit point dom la leaf les petits
points glanés d'accord un petit poêle au
sénat jusqu'à 1,3 à redire les allées
des arts de paris c'est la couleur
directe à l'image il commence sa
toilette comme un jeu dernier patrick
bernier fois ça se joue sur ce point je
sors ce repas est parti c'est la balle
de match
si patrick de la répétition tout à
l'heure ça a été filmé patrick je vous
avez quoi comme je vous aime beaucoup
oui j'ai change je prends votre cage à
et je vais faire ah voila voila je
prends je prends votre gaz patrick et je
vais faire le yoga avec gilles verdez
voilà nous le fera nu on le fera tous
les deux voilà pourquoi ce qu'on le
fasse le 13 juillet pour fêter la
victoire de la france de la cobra là
vous vous êtes sûr que la france va être
championne du monde
abat d'abord d'accord pas si la france
est championne du monde y gagne si la
france est championne du monde vous fait
toute l'année prochaine